As the saying goes ‘It’s not the size
that counts, it’s how you use it’ - but
does this long standing phrase ring true in
the hugely debated topic of penis size? Does
your member actually make a difference in
attractiveness or ability to pleasure your
partner?
Interestingly, humans have the largest penis
of any primate, both in absolute size and
relative to body proportion...so you can be
proud of that! Through our evolutionary history,
females likely developed an interest and preference
for penis shape and size - much like how female
peacocks have a preference for a male with
stunning feathers. As a result, they chose
mates with larger penises, ultimately passing
on those genes. This is know as sexual selection.
It also may have been an advantage for males,
as a longer penis is more efficient at removing
the sperm of rival males during intercourse.
The longer your depth of thrust, the better
semen displacement, ensuring your genes get
passed on.
One particular study found that some women
experience more frequent vaginal orgasms with
longer penises, suggesting that it may be
able to stimulate the entire length of the
vagina and the cervix. However, it’s important
to note that women experience different types
of orgasms; in fact, vaginal and clitoral
orgasms may be completely separate phenomena
- they use different nerves, and even stimulate
different areas of the brain. Even the coveted
“G-Spot”, another sexually sensitive area
in women, is located only ⅓ of the way into
the vagina. Apart from this, many surveys
of women have found that they’re not nearly
as concerned with size, as men might think,
and preferences vary. However, studies on
homosexual men have shown that they regard
a larger penis as ideal.
Another study in 2013 actually found that
flaccid penis size may also be a major factor
in male attractiveness - even before sexual
contact. Which may seem odd considering we
wear clothes nowadays; but for our ancestors,
the genitals would have been visible. In the
study, women were asked to rank the attractiveness
of males based on computer generated images
reflecting different body types and penis
sizes. From this, it was clear that not only
were taller and more fit men much more desirable,
but flaccid penis size played a role in their
perceived attractiveness too. The larger the
penis, the higher they were rated. But there
was a limit - a flaccid penis larger than
about 7.6 cm and attractiveness began to diminish.
It would seem a penis in proportion may be
most desirable. After all, over exaggerated
traits - even those related to attractiveness
- can often be a sign of problems.
And it turns out that the person attached
to the penis makes a difference too - with
most all studies showing confidence, enjoyable
personality, and attraction being the best
predictor of sexual satisfaction. Ultimately,
while size does seem to matter in some ways,
bigger isn’t always better!
Just be glad you don’t have a Bean Weevels
penis. We break down some of the craziest
genitals nature has to offer in our new AsapTHOUGHT
video. Seriously, there is some crazy stuff
out there, so be sure to check the video out
- click the screen or use the link in the
description! And subscribe for more weekly
science videos!